we also saw some gameplay of recore for
the very first time and this is KJ an
Funes sort of getting his fingers in
there little [ __ ] we're saying was a
bunch of the creative team behind
Metroid Prime yeah what was your take on
I'm like um kind of glad they showed
more of like how the robots are gonna be
how you're like building up a team it
seems like I don't know if they're gonna
carry each and I'm through the entire
game or how that's going to work but I
mean the way that they were showing its
kind of she was using one that was like
a grappling hook almost yes seems like I
don't know like almost like a megaman
vibe obviously Inafune is attached to it
but it looks like you're gaining these
actual abilities which that also strikes
me as the Metroid Prime aspect and I'm
interested in kind of the exploring that
new world have these item gates that you
get through and learned all these new
abilities as you're going kind of seems
like I'd still don't completely
understand what the game is like in
terms of its overarching structure and
it looks open world but I have no idea
yeah maybe a sub Metroidvania thing as
well you're sort of doubling back when
you got different robots and exploring
that way what did you think rob was I
kind of like it on paper I'm willing to
like anyone who like try something new a
game plan weddings I give a shot didn't
look like a game that was like
particularly I mean it came after games
like forts and gears so maybe in my eyes
were just readjusting yeah but what did
you think I'm probably showing my age
here but I reminds me of jet force
Gemini okay on the n64 right yeah that
third-person shootings or game or
cinnamon ishment actually oh gods yeah
I'm thrown out in about 10 20 years ok
I've I like those sort of games that
yeah Arkady third person shooters III
and also I think it was really important
Michael showed off a game like there's
something which stood out a little bit
right on the you know famous franchise
new number famous franchise number sort
of thing that they were going for so I
was quite impressed by this I thought it
had it popped in the press conference
all right
other